bonjour didier lalande
bonjour merci beaucoup d'être en direct
avec nous ce matin sur rtl france vous
avez décidé donc de porter plainte
contre emmanuel macron une plainte
évidemment symbolique mais mais tout de
même après les propos où le chef de
l'état disait vouloir emmerder une
partie des français ceux qui n'étaient
pas vaccinés pourquoi cette démarche
c'est une démarche qui a été qu'ils
n'étaient pas du tout pour lui
et on a malheureusement on le chat ne ça
fonctionne alors je vous repose la
question pardon alesis
oui je disais que c'était une décision
qui n'était pas du tout prémédité en
réalité j'ai écouté une commune
l'information continue lundi soir et
c'était quelques heures après emmanuel
macron et reçu les lecteurs du parisien
à l'elysée et j'étais sidéré d'entendre
ce qui était rapporté sur les propos
qu'il avait tenus concernant les gens
qui n'étaient pas vaccinés et donc à
partir de là j'ai pas très bien dormi en
vérité et le lendemain matin juste envie
de me raser puis je me disais mais
didier c'est pas possible tu peux pas je
veux pas laisser passer quelque chose
comme ça et je suis j'ai pris la
décision d'aller à la gendarmerie
l'après midi et avec le temps j'ai été
très bien reçu par la gêne la gendarme
qui a pris ma déposition j'ai porté
plainte et oui contre le président de
république et en sortant deux
commissariats de la gendarmerie
j'ai pris la décision de me faire
connaître en fait ma démarche parce que
je me suis dit finalement tout citoyen
en france peut s'exprimer
autrement que par les manifestations
peut parler pétition que par tout un tas
de choses qui n'ont pas beaucoup
d'effets mais se faire entendre sa
propre voix en tout pas déjà pour moi ça
m'a fait beaucoup de bien voilà c'était
ça le faut parce qu'il faut dire vous
vous êtes senti insulté
avait clairement non seulement le fait
de long terme que je vais pas répéter
passe
connexion
malheureusement on va réessayer didier
lalande vous vous êtes donc senti
insulté après les propos du chef de
l'état
oui je me suis sentie insultée et aussi
dans ma citoyenneté puisque
d'ampli considère que les gens qui ne
sont pas vaccinés sont des
irresponsables et ne méritait pas la
citoyenneté et là je veux dire ça a été
vraiment la cerise sur le gâteau je
comprends pas comme président de la
république puis c'est à dire des choses
comme ça c'est à dire attiser la haine
des gens les uns contre les autres
stigmatiser une partie de la compilation
dont il est responsable
ollier hier j'ai reçu beaucoup de
messages de soutien mais aussi des
messages haineux parmi ceux là il y
avait un il y avait un ancien gendarme à
la retraite comme moi qui ici insurgé
contre ma démarche et au bout d'un
moment je lui ai dit mais vous étiez le
nombre de fonctionnaires est-ce que vous
sur un rond point vous vous seriez
permis en comprenant les papiers un
automobiliste de tenir des propos comme
ça
et votre patron par contre aujourd'hui
lui c'est le père mais est ce que vous
trouvez que c'est normal vous aviez un
code de déontologie nous vous avez une
formation pour vous adresser au public
on peut pas imaginer que le patron
d'eads au fil de toutes les
administrations lui-même montrent-elles
exemple aux gens qui travaillent pour
l'état et finalement c'est d'entretien
c'est chimie très cordialement le seul
monsieur était finalement d'accord avec
moi sur parce que c'est vraiment le sens
de la planète au delà de de la
vaccination
c'est en fait
ça ça pourrait être un autre sujet un
président ne peut pas faire ça et
c'était vraiment le fond du dépôt de
maintenant c'est le fait qu'il qu'il n'
y est le statut de citoyen pour ces
irresponsables dont ils vous vous
affuble en tout cas dans le terme
vous êtes affublé par le chef de l'état
vous n'êtes pas donc pas vacciner
comment est ce que vous le vivez est-ce
que c'est pas trop compliqué de vivre
avec ça
écoutez moi je les sens je n'avais pas
agresser les gens les députés de la
république en marche leur domicile moi
je suis dans la campagne j'ai manifesté
effectivement contre le passé ni terres
déjà l'été dernier
et j'ai j'ai été très heureux de voir
que dans les manifestations on va y
avait des gens de toutes sortes qui
était là il y avait aussi des gens
vaccinés j'étais encore vendre le samedi
aussi à la petite manifestation et des
gens étaient vaccinés et prenez la
parole comme contre contre 7,7 pression
et cet apartheid qui est créée en france
et ça ça te rend bientôt parce que je me
sois de ne pas être vaccinés vous n'avez
pas tort tout simplement pour votre
santé
d'un côté moi j'assume finalement
moi je n'ai pas peur de la mort et ça
c'est vraiment celle arme absolue contre
la contre la population agiter la peur
et on voit que finalement ça fonctionne
toujours très bien
moi je dis si je suis prêt à assumer un
mot à assumer mon choix si un jour un
vaccin unique sur le marché et que
premièrement il n'a pas d'effets
secondaires
notables que le deuxièmement il met un
terme à la pandémie
et je suis parti là que je fais me ferai
peut être vaccinés dans d'un de cette
façon-là envoyé une rumeur dit isner qui
vous font peur ou le fait qu'on n'ait
pas suffisamment d'information sur ces
effets secondaires
alors on n'a pas d'informations en
société qui est secondaire si on les
cherche pas on peut les trouver mais
ce qui ce qui est c'est qu'il me
touche si vous voulez c'est regarder ce
qui s'est passé au mois de décembre
cette vague de vaccination qui les a eus
et finalement on a une augmentation des
à la coupe vides partout en france avec
les restrictions qui vont avec moi
j'appelle pas ça un vaccin
oui à voir que ça c'est pas ça mais
voilà pourquoi celle-ci est une des
raisons de mon choix et au jour le jour
donc vous vous protégez vous même
j'imagine par par d'autres moyens
selon moi je respecte jugé ces barrières
les contraintes et qui auquel on me
soumets donc comme vous tous mes
concitoyens là on fait le mieux possible
pour éviter de se contaminer de
contaminer les autres à ce jour moi je
n'ai pas été malade dans ma famille des
gens ont été vaccinées sur le premier
malade
c'est de la com' ville et certains sont
tombés malades suite à la vaccination
donc je peux témoigner aussi de choses
là dans ma famille aussi autour de moi
voyez serment par le mais c'est pourtant
la vérité qu répondez vous donc au chef
de l'état parce que ses propos il les a
dit suite aux propos d'aidés soignants
qui se disent débordés justement par des
non vaccinés qui finissent aux urgences
que répondez vous au chef de l'état sur
cet argument
mais moi je sais pas je ne suis pas
responsable de la politique sanitaire du
gouvernement depuis le début de la
mandature dessus d'un cran antec ce que
je constate c'est que les manifestations
de colère des services hospitaliers ont
vraiment précédé la crise de sanitaires
et donc évidemment la crise sanitaire
est venu encore un peu plus renforcé le
mal-être des hôpitaux des hôpitaux nous
avons dans les manifestations l'été
dernier nous sommes allés souvent devant
devant l'hôpital pour soutenir les
soignants les infirmières étaient peu à
la fenêtre et que nous saluer voyez je
pense qu'il faut pas se tromper de cible
aujourd'hui aujourd'hui c'est qu'il faut
faire c'est mettre le paquet sur les
services hospitaliers ouvrir des lits
former des gens il faut pas trois ans
pour former un infirmier en réanimation
tout ça est possible plutôt que de s'y
mettre afin de dévier le débat est de
mettre la responsabilité sur des gens
qui font le choix libre de 6 le pas
vacciner et qui sont tout à fait dans la
légalité en plus parce qu'on peut pas
même si on peut se poser sinon pourquoi
c'est l'accès n'est pas rendue
obligatoire celle de leur mettre la puce
à l'oreille de beaucoup on va voir cela
merci beaucoup en tout cas pour votre
témoignage guy lalande ce matin dans la
matinale rt france